[Music]
welcome to ear biscuits I'm link and I'm
Rhett this week at the round table of
dim lighting we are exploring the
question how has ear biscuits changed
over the course of 200 episode that's
right this is the Bicentennial yes we've
been going for 200 years
200 episode you can you say Bicentennial
when you're talking about just the
number or does it have to be the year
not any more than you have but I think
you good
I think you've reached the quota I've
got a couple in my back pocket you know
what it's been a pleasure sitting here
for all too well there's been a few
exceptions but well you're saying it
like this is the last episode at this
roundtable a pleasure we're stopping at
200 for 200 injured it wow I mean this
is a milestone so you know I like to get
sentimental so in this episode I asked
Kiko to pull some clips that span the
history of ear biscuits to kind of jog
our memory of some things that we've
been through here at the at the round
table and reminisce probably analyze and
pontificate about the future perhaps if
you've been with us since the beginning
or if you've done what some people do
and that is you you get in late but then
you go home early you go back early yeah
and you catch up you've known you've
learned that this what this show is has
evolved pretty significantly yeah so I
think that I mean first of all the clips
that we're gonna be playing are mostly
well not mostly we kind of it sort of it
spans the changes but we are going to
spend quite a bit of time talking
hearing from some of those people we had
as guests early on but then we'll talk
about what the show has become and what
we think about that yeah
what does ear biscuits mean to us and
I think we've got a handle on what it
means to you as a listener as well so
the interaction between those two things
I think I think we'll lay in there I'm
getting before we get into I just want
to say I'm getting I'm getting whiffs of
myself this is not the first time or the
last that I've done what I did this
morning which was for the past few days
I've been rubbing my deodorant stick
sands deodorant on my underarms
you know how when it basically runs out
but you you don't have a new one so it's
like well I'm I bet there's I bet I
can't see it
but there's some deodorant on on there
and I'm just gonna rub harder oh how
many family members do you have uh five
other ones including the dog or six if
Britain happens to be in town okay you
don't my boys my boys have deodorant oh
I've talked to you about how big my
house is I mean I'm so huge to go down
there and get there if that's what your
option number one is to use your wife's
deodorant that's what I've done that's
what I switched to and now I'm getting
wafts so of this powder scent that's
literally giving me a headache
I was gonna say something I was gonna
compliment you but it's like I'm in a
frickin baby powder factory like I've
never gone up to my wife secret and it I
think its degree antiperspirant and
deodorant powder scent apparently not a
sponsor the lady's like I smell like
powder well when I get close to her she
also hits that mythical number nine that
really draws me that store but this
powders not can you smell it
I'm oh I'm gonna wash my Jack I can't
smell a lot of things so I don't know if
I'm a great candidate for for for that
it's ahead sickness I'm having trouble
with it I'm thinking about it I like it
wiping down my armpits it's going
because the past two days I've been
stinking like the left pit not the right
one but I don't use antiperspirant so
today I also feel like not only am I
getting powdered up but I'm also getting
clogged up because you know I don't use
that in a purse right and you know what
it will negatively affect you okay so
I'd like one day of it
well I I went we talking about cancer no
aluminum no no I went for I'd say three
days okay I don't know if you've ever
talked about this on your biscuits but
we had a friend Nick who told us to take
the old spice challenge which I don't
even know if the old spice challenge is
what we are he interpreted it to be
right but he said it was when you go
deodorant only and you stop
antiperspirant and he's like after a
certain period of time it varies from
person to person you will no longer need
antiperspirant now I will say that
neither of us are very sweaty guys you
know in fact and I'm not saying this as
a point of you know Baraka Toshio yeah
I'm saying it because Ana who did hair
and makeup for buddy system during a
very hot summer and then has also done
hair makeup for GM for quite some time
she said she talks about how some actors
are super sweating he had to like take
like certain precautions they're gonna
sweat through their stuff you have to
give them special things you know and
she's like you guys are very on the low
end of sweatiness so maybe this doesn't
apply to everybody but both of us took
the Old Spice challenge went straight
deodorant I would say within and I
didn't even do it with Old Spice yeah
yeah you're I don't remember what I did
but the deal I'll keep call it the
deodorant channel channel the deodorant
channel it's a new YouTube channel why
did I say I don't know well we had a
challenge because we're youtubers so and
because you know even when you use any
purse print if you forget to use any
purse / for that day sometimes you'll
just be in the middle of a non-stressful
activity and you feel like a drip come
down you're like a fountain like a
sprout it'll sprout since taking the
deodorant channel cystic and the
deodorant shared subscribing to the
deodorant channel I haven't had that
drip egde I haven't either
ever
until oh I ran out of deodorant but you
know what I was doing I made a mistake
man I made I made a big mistake I went
to I actually went to the drugstore to
get deodorant to restock and I think I
do you got distracted by gummy bears
again didn't you know I you I got like a
couple of old spices okay you know
different I fall for their marketing and
the way they talk about right the the
funny stuff that it says on there and
it's just deodorant at this point I
don't need the antiperspirant so I just
any deodorant will work but there was
this thing on the top in the natural
section and it said I think I said
magnesium based or something like that
it was like no aluminum magnesium basing
it had and it was also a we had charcoal
in it and I just thought that's such a
trend I don't know why I have I don't
have any need for it I just got it cuz I
was like hmm cool you know new I wonder
if and here's what I said to myself I
wonder if there are some circumstances
in which I still might need an any purse
pray let me test this out since this
doesn't even though I don't believe no
for the past four years at least maybe
six since we've taken to subscribe to
the other singers but I and I personally
don't believe in the aluminum thing I
think the aluminum thing being bad for
you is is bad science based on the last
time that I looked at it but why take a
chance right so I used this stuff for
three days mm-hmm
and then the reason I stopped using it
is because it was so hard it would rip
the hair under my arms out it just ate
what it didn't have the smooth like just
go across there real fast so I stopped
using it went back to the old spice that
day drip it's triple I mean trickle I
don't understand words are coming on
what's happening I don't understand how
your body is adjusting to this but it
was like my body got the cue that it was
okay to evacuate watered under my
underarms but within three or four days
you back back to I was back to normal
acting normal so I encourage everybody
to do that you know unless you're just a
sweaty person I get the do de I
do get Old Spice because I also fall for
it I mean I got a hand it to it also
smells good but I don't get really
expecting good smelling but the one I
get is Fiji and the main reason I do is
I've had few because I've been to Fiji
now that I've been to Fiji every morning
my armpits go back to Fiji so I got I
got to go in for some more feeds yeah I
know I'm telling I completely got on the
feed the feed so you know I was
self-conscious about the powder I'm glad
to hear that you can't smell it but I'm
sorry to hear that you can't smell
that's gonna really put a damper I don't
wanna put that a damper on our 200th
celebration that we're that we're in the
middle as long as there's nothing else
to smell I'll be fine I mean we're not
gonna we're gonna you know you can
access memories through smell and I had
this whole thing I was gonna bring in
like oh this is episode you were real
and articles of clothing from past
guests well you know how we always snip
off a little part of their clothes
well we haven't listened to these clips
together we'll do that we'll go on a joy
ride back through ear biscuits
but first let's plug some merch I mean I
can't talk about this ear biscuits mug
enough we'll talk about it some more
when you drink out of it it's like it's
like putting a podcast in your mouth
that's that's a great analogy and I
would also say that I didn't realize
until recently that this mug is very
large you're eating our conversations a
lot of people don't understand how big
the mugs are because we're very large
people I saw that people didn't like
them to be big so we were gonna like
downplay that no no I mean you're so
small what do you what are you trying to
do what are you trying to slip your mug
you're trying to take it on a plane
don't take it on a plane just put it in
the cabinet use it in the morning I love
a big mug if there's more you get more
liquid in a bigger mug I mean it's not a
thermos we're not talking thermos
capacity I'm just saying it's larger
I've made you and create Sam it's not
Alice I'm just saying it looks like a
normal mug but it's a slightly extra
large mug because we're slightly extra
large people and I go through a full
whatever this is your biscuits mug of
tea or water at least every this is 64
ounces
it's like a big gulp if you want to get
a big gulp your biscuits mug go to a
mythical store or actually mythical
mythical store which is that mythical
daaad store that's what I meant all
right I'm just I've got some clips that
are in chronological order so let's just
start at the beginning this is well this
is episode three released on your
birthday October 11th of 2013 I was so
young back then mid 30s I believe grace
was our full life ahead of me but um
this is uh this is a clip of shane
dawson shanedawsontv so uh let's listen
to this very short clip you know when I
was a kid I grew up on horror movies not
horror movie horror horror horror horror
movies I grew up that's all I watched
it's all I knew I still that's all I
watched really so I have had it was so
desensitized to violence and cussing and
boobs and all of that stuff so for me I
wanted to be genuine and authentic with
what I thought was funny what I thought
was cool and I was into dark humor and
all that stuff and I was like maybe
there's other kids out there that are
like that too and when YouTube first
started it was those kids now it's a
little more mainstream but back then it
was like the dark gothic kids at school
and that's what they thought was funny
too and my first one of my first
sketches was about phone sex where I had
phone sex with a girl and she ended up
like killing somebody I don't know it
was very dark and and yeah like and
that's just what I knew and then the
moral was phone sex kills yeah the moral
was there's always youth if you think
your life is bad there's always somebody
out there whose life is worse than yours
and you should appreciate what you have
it was always like the morals were very
very loosely tied to it but my whole
thing now is I look at it like okay now
my goal is just to give five minutes of
entertainment to somebody who needs it
and if there's a moral great if there's
not at least they got five minutes of
free entertainment and and then
hopefully now just keep proving people
like oh I can actually direct because my
goal now which has been my goal since I
was five is to direct so now
not really in my videos anymore and all
my last like hit videos I guess so hard
nowadays to get a hit but like my last
couple like good videos I haven't even
been in like my last couple parodies I
wasn't even in mm-hmm
just behind the scenes writing directing
so that's kind of my goal now is to take
a little step back end of clip now I'm
gonna say that every time this is us
actually talking I'm not gonna say that
anymore because know that I'm talking
about you not abuse so um a couple of
things about that well I've got a number
of thoughts but I'm not gonna I'm not
gonna hog all other thoughts here you
know the fact really he talked about
five minutes you know talk about giving
somebody five a five minute video and
then also talking about how it's hard to
find a hit and how it's he's not even in
a lot of his videos anymore and then
what inspires you very interesting to me
it just shows you that Shane's mentality
has always been experimenting and he's
always he's always had his his sights
set on succeeding at this platform which
this may sound like an overly simplistic
statement but if you don't commit to
trying to win at the game that is
YouTube you will not end up being it you
may have a successful sort of stint as a
youtuber but longevity in this game is
recognizing it as somewhat of a game
that has to be played the rules
constantly change evolve or die and he's
done that you know I mean thought a
little bit about his dark humor which if
you've been following anything you know
his dark humor has has gotten him into
trouble from time to time but I think
the interesting thing about him saying
that he was moving into this place where
he was directing and also not being on
camera and then you think about six
years later where he's at now which is
still kind of directing and producing
but he has reinserted himself into the
center of his content because that turns
out that's what worked and also I can
think of many examples where that hasn't
worked on YouTube since it's so
personality based and also he's gone to
the opposite extreme he's not tell about
five minutes he's
talking about like an hour and a half I
mean what is the well over an hour
documentary done almost two hourly to
our length some of those I know I'm just
very grateful that Shane is doing well
and it's so relevant more so than ever
well maybe I want to say that just as
relevant as he was in his previous
versions I'm just so glad there's people
who've been around who know how YouTube
used to be and they're still making it
work that gives us hope because that's
obviously what we're continuing to work
hard to do stay relevant
stay on this thing so I'm grateful for
Shane because from a selfish standpoint
it gives me hope it was awesome I was
also very grateful that he came on the
show because it's not the type of thing
that he loves to do I don't think no he
didn't you know I mean he still doesn't
hey and I you know we should acknowledge
that if Shane hadn't done his podcast
I'm sure we've said this before I don't
know that we would have considered doing
a podcast
it wasn't the only factor by any means
but it was a factor he was not only
doing a podcast but it was he was doing
well and it seemed to be able to support
itself financially it was a business
model there yeah because you know we
just can't justify you know doing
something it was speculated for a few
years I don't think we were making money
off the podcast it weren't sponsors
involved in the very early but the plan
was that there would be and if you only
listen now yeah Shane is Shane was the
third guest of many guests to at least
two years worth a guest let's go ahead
and go to another guest episode 25
released on March 21st of 2014 this is
colleen ballinger
she also played Miranda in part of the
ear biscuit
she came on as Miranda and then she left
and came back is going yeah yeah and I
don't know I think this is gonna be a :
clip but I don't know for sure you're
obviously talented not only as a
comedian
as a singer in a performer so you know
how do you balance that when you think
about the future and you're like okay
well I've got these two tracks you know
I hope the Miranda will keel over at
some point or this is I'm gonna take
this all the way like what are you yeah
no I don't want to kill Miranda you know
I think Miranda will live as long as
people want to watch she's gonna get
pregnant and good that's exciting you
know she's gonna go through it all with
me
are you pregnant I'm this is the
announcement I'm pregnant guys okay I
wanna that's the key to vows you're
working if somebody's got to get
pregnant on this show well and lo and
behold she did get pregnant Miranda got
pregnant so that was that was a that was
a forecast that was a premonition so you
did hear it first
kollene is pregnant you heard it first
on ear biscuits it just it wasn't true
at the time and you know she has and the
reason I asked the question about are
you going to kill Miranda as you never
know how people feel about the thing
that everybody loves about what they do
yeah and the thing that everyone has
latched on a lot of times it was like
well that wasn't even supposed to be the
thing really what I want to do is this
and she is um she's got a role in a mall
a Broadway musical
what is it waitress it sounds right yeah
gratulations she's gonna she's gonna do
a little run there but which is that's
been her dream forever and she's not
doing it as Miranda nope and she and she
she got pregnant and then had a baby
that's usually what happens after
pregnancy yep and then it was so a
little boy that's are all over her
Instagram so III would like to say we
broke that story okay that you can say
that and you know I think the thing
about kollene as well I mean going back
to 2014 and I and I think this is pretty
much the case with I don't want to get
ahead of myself but we don't have any
examples of like you remember when
so-and-so was really
we interview them and now they're
completely off the map we don't I'm sure
we could come up with examples through
that but we're not doing that because
we're nice guys but the way that her
career has has evolved and how she is
not as she isn't as reliant on the
YouTube game as she once was because I
mean she's still doing very well
she had a Netflix show but she had a
Netflix special that's out now and she
had and just her touring that she's done
I mean I I'm sure that's gonna slow down
or has slowed down because of the baby
but so much touring that was super
successful and now getting these
traditional roles she's she's playing
the the worldwide game she met her baby
daddy on her Netflix show she did yeah
cuz he was the he was the love interest
on the show you know that's why you got
to be careful who you cast if you're if
you're an executive producer on your
show you got a cast somebody that you
want to hook up with lesson learnt you
know make those babies casting that's
probably illegal
like you can't yeah let's not get into
that yeah let's just say relationally if
you want to if you want to get to know
somebody you could cast them but let's
just make it well I'm not making it
anything I'm not making it anything so
you can say I'm gonna make it you don't
say let's make it because I didn't make
it anything to begin with episode 29
released on April 18 2014
Troye Sivan and then we recorded this
one at VidCon so it may sound a little
different how many details can we get
out of your your secret project that
you're working on that you mentioned it
mmm yeah go I'll say it's potentially
the biggest thing that I've ever done in
my whole life
like work wise okay um I've been working
really really really hard on for like I
guess just under a year now you there's
gonna be a big launch some but you've
written it maybe it took a while to
write maybe you know and I'm writing it
now can I
can I see your palm like yeah that's
gonna help me go ahead but okay yeah
we've got the lifeline here taking a
left so it's not a thing it's a how how
mean am I going to be when I die it's an
album I can look at you know your your
palm and tell it's a it's a blockbuster
album and Rhett you were you nailed it
he did not he did not say he didn't
really respond to your prediction
because he knew it was absolutely true
100% true and the look on his face which
we did not we did not have video video
that at the time was a oh yeah he's got
me totally right his first major-label
EP t ry x ii i don't know if you if you
spell it out if you say it cuz I'm a dad
peaked at number five on the US
Billboard 200 had another album since
then he's he's like he like shows up to
perform a Taylor Swift yeah he is in a
different stratosphere the music has
kind of the music things kind of worked
kind of words for Troy and you know what
all because of you Rhett because you
know up until that moment this is the
thing I didn't want to say it turns out
that the thing that Troy was working on
was not an album it was a it was a
claymation movie
and that he has been a lot of time on
the claymation takes forever and when I
said album once the camera stopped
rolling once the the we stopped
recording he was like you know what it's
actually a claymation thing but now that
you said album I'm probably probably
doing album and I haven't heard from
Troy sense but that's pretty cool I mean
as you you know I want to talk about how
what we think about this interview phase
of your biscuits but don't let's just
get through a couple more of these
interviewer Clips this next one skipping
forward to May 9th of 2014 this is
episode 32 with a comedy duo known as
smosh smosh showcase masha
you know the
overall plan for Smosh isn't just about
Ian and I so our main focus isn't let's
go do a movie let's go be a huge
Hollywood hotshots or whatever let's
let's grow the brand and keep our comedy
alive and as many different forms as we
can we have our gaming channel we have a
cartoon channel we're trying to
introduce new personalities I totally
get our humor that we think our audience
will like you know like they love all
the Smosh games guys now and they love
Mari so those those have been some
personalities that we've introduced that
I totally get it
so you're so more of that getting to
other other Smosh properties yeah other
people that we really love that we know
that our audience will totally get yeah
because I mean like we can't we can't
create 50 shows ourselves but we can
create other shows that other people
make that our audience can enjoy just as
much as they enjoy watching our shows
and that's and I think that's that's
cool guess I just need to say thanks for
all that strategic development you know
they turned a corner at that point in
terms of casting you know expanding the
Smosh cast to include everyone that we
know very well now because they work in
our building and then Anthony and in
they you know they separated creatively
and if you listen back to that podcast I
think yeah in hindsight you can probably
read into it maybe more than was
actually there but that's if that's a
valid exercise if you want to do it to
see how if you want to over-interpret
some creative tension or just creative
trajectories being kind of splitting
that was so pretty pretty early
yeah the 2014 it would be another what
four years before Anthony left I mean I
don't know if I would have known that we
would have acquired Smosh and brought
them in-house and you know given in the
freedom with his team to continue to
create as they
I just don't know how I feel doing that
interview it's like I'd probably be like
that's why I can't be a time traveller
cuz I beat I don't have this weird grin
on my face like what's wrong with you
man
well I mean that we had no point of
reference absolutely no I mean I would
say that up until the moment that it
started to seem like it could happen we
had no point of reference for acquiring
you know I'm saying it well that wasn't
really it wasn't really on our minds it
wasn't part of the strategic plan but
yeah they go because we've you know
we've looked up to Smosh for a really
long time you go back to the very
beginning but when like probably when we
started our YouTube channel they were
they had to be number one it was either
them yeah barats and bereta no they were
they were number one historically they
are in the top five maybe the top three
most subscribed channels on YouTube in
terms of like longevity obviously
holding that title for a very long time
yeah obviously PewDiePie is up at the
top which we also have an interview with
him I don't think we're not gonna we
don't have a clip of of talking with
Felix but um but you talked about the
another clip we're not gonna play but I
want to talk about it because it is the
wasabi brothers we had the wasabi bros
on yeah and we actually so whenever we
have a duo on we talked about they're
like creative dynamic relational dynamic
all that stuff and just to you know from
one duo to another let's talk about that
and how you work through things and when
we started asking those questions about
how you work through things in
differences etc with the wasabi Bros it
became very evident to us and you can go
back and listen to the episode that this
didn't seem like something that was
gonna last and then I would say that
within I don't know it was less than a
year it might have been a few months
right
they announced that they were separating
Roy and Alex Roy he's gonna do a bunch
of bathing and stuff yeah they both gone
to be very successful
visually but yeah it was you know they
didn't it didn't seem like they had
necessarily the commitment to be like
this is us doing this together or bust
and that usually is required and even
when you do have that commitment
sometimes it doesn't work out yeah I
think that was April 30th 2018 when when
that finally came to it
no like link was saying you know the
majority of the episodes early on were
these interviews yeah because that was
the we probably have said this before
but we were really influenced by Marc
Maron WTF podcast at the time and that
he was interviewing these traditional
celebrities and getting into very
personal things and this wasn't this
wasn't something we had any experience
with also it's it's a little bit it's a
little bit odd to dine it there's a
dynamic when two guys are interviewing
one person typically on a personal level
and so it's kind of like uh okay this is
this is an interesting dynamic probably
don't need two people to ask a question
where 70 ask questions and interview
somebody where 75 to 80% of the content
is going to be the answers that this
person is giving I mean it's it there
was some cool things that happen with us
kind of bouncing things off of each
other if there's you knows two different
perspectives applied to it but we both
have a lot to say yeah you know what I'm
saying and and so every once in a while
even back then we would work in one of
these episodes where it was just hey
let's just talk to each other but the
when we decided to do the podcast we
immediately went to the interview thing
because there were so many people doing
that especially in the comedy world like
you said but no one was doing it in the
way it in that deep kind of
introspective analytical raw way with
youtubers so I would I was very excited
about that in terms of actually I felt
like it was like collecting youtuber
interview
use as a time capsule and I'm very proud
of the interviews that we did because I
do think it represented everyone's story
up into that point how they got to that
point and being so successful on YouTube
they were and I do think as you sort of
still go back and see that YouTube has
changed so much that a lot of the
success paths that they took are no
longer viable paths you know because
YouTube is a different thing it works
differently everything's different about
everything so but I still think it's a
time capsule you know I know for the
Felix interview it was it was very
obvious to us that he had never really
to the level that we were trying to get
him to analyze his own success really
grappled with that and it was a
combination of somebody who was willing
to ask those kinds of questions but also
had the insight into what they were
doing because it was what we were doing
it's it's the reason that Marc Maron's
podcast work so well is he's talking to
comedians and performers and he's a
comedian and performer yeah and so we
and I think it had to do with our age
you know I think we were already old
yeah in terms of the ecosystem of
YouTube and so and we had been doing it
for a while we had we knew a lot of
these people and they respected us
enough to say yeah we'll come in and
talk to you and then it cut you know it
took on a life of its own because that's
a guest driven podcast works differently
than you know talent driven cut I'm
using the term talent loosely where it's
just like two guys you're going to talk
to each other every single host driven
you know it works differently and it
draws people in a different way so there
were people who were coming into an ear
biscuits podcast because of the guests
and we've kind of relied on that for you
know basically the entire first and
second season yeah but like you said we
would well and I did want to have one
thing I do think that there was a
question in our minds I think when we
first came up with what your biscuits is
gonna be that
do we do people want to hear us talk for
an hour do we want to talk for an hour
you know I don't think we never
considered it to the it we moved to the
interview sitting so quickly that I just
wonder if we if we questioned whether
what we're doing what we're doing now is
just the two of us is something that
would be viable you know I think we I
think we thought that we needed the name
recognition of the guests to drive
interest but like you said we even in
the midst of doing interviews we did
pepper in some episodes that were just
the two of us talking and this next one
episode 42 released July 25th 2014
called obsession we talked about your
layers mm-hmm lit clip of that Rhett
goes through a series of obsessions like
a fashion designer goes through new
outfits
these are semi in chronological order
ultralights
chiropractic crow hunting wine pairings
fossils in geology crown victorias
barbecue hot yoga juicing paddleboarding
for wheeling now that was edited you
don't speak that you don't speak that
quickly
no I move it to speed of conversation
and that was the speed of an edit
because and the list could have gone on
and on no I think that was the list at
the time and then we kind of unpacked
the dynamic associated with it but I'm
what do you think when you hear that
list I think about I'm like oh yeah yeah
what do you mean what do you mean mmm
yeah that's good that's good ultra
lights I gotta get back on that gotta
get my those fossils yeah I just
just look at my fossils yesterday I did
I was rearranging some things and I
looked at some fossils I was like hmm I
get more of these fossils now you're
adding on to the layers I think that's
the other way is that we can add to this
list now the other way to look at it
well you know is I think about the so
the last two mentioned being
paddleboarding and in four-wheeling
off-roading whatever you call it yeah
our to that we did together and I think
the fact that we haven't done we haven't
gone on an off-roading trip in at least
two years I would say
and we've paddleboarded once in the past
six months maybe right I think that it
is indicative of a number of factors I
think it's due to a number of factors
one professionally are you going
straight white t-shirt no I / taking my
jacket off professionally we and we were
just talking about this yesterday we are
as busy we're always busier than we're
always as busy as we've ever been right
and I think that we're now we're not
currently like in the middle of shooting
you know half-hour comedy while trying
to like work gmm into it at the same
time that's not currently happening but
there's just so many little things that
were kind of keeping up with that we've
got less time when it comes to just
there's so many professional
responsibilities but also our kids have
gotten to an age where they always have
stuff going on that you have to be a
part of
so yeah let's blame it on the kids are
you saying you did I agree with that no
I'm saying that was I'm not blaming the
kids I know it I agree there's things
like they have so much to do and yours
you got two of them I got three of them
and it's like I don't make I do not make
weekend plans anymore
I mean I'll make weekend plans like way
in advance like okay I'm gonna go
someplace for my anniversary or whatever
but I know that it's like well you likes
gonna have a basketball game or he's
gonna have some practice on the other
side of town Shepherds gonna have a
birthday party or you gonna have to go
to this golf practice or whatever and
it's just a given that at this stage in
their lives they are going to have these
things that they have to do and you
combine that with the fact that
there's just so much to like and even
when we do go do things like
paddleboarding we it let the last time
we went paddleboarding we turn it into
like a day of brainstorming we it was
like hey let's go get out the ocean and
then let's go and sit down and
brainstorm a bunch of ideas ideas that
were actually you know currently working
on in one form or another but are you
saying you don't have any layers your
life is such that you can no longer have
an obsession I think that I thought the
I mean the the lights in the house were
kind of an obsession but it's that well
more of an installation I would say that
that is a you know I would say home
stuff is an obsession for both of us I
would say the the most recent layer is
just reading horror novels I think that
you know that's when you can fit in
getting you know writing the novel
looking for some inspiration and then
continuing to think about where we could
go with that story you know I'd say
that's the latest thing is I'm consuming
a lot of thriller slash horror novels
but in terms of things that require
buying equipment and I anticipate
getting more back into the art of
barbecue when we redo the outside and
I've got this my got my eye on this this
grill that I want or whatever but it's
not like you know the last time I like
smoke the pork but for a large group of
people again that's I got a planet I got
it I gotta get ready tonight before I
got to spend six to eight hours on the
day of like but at least you're at home
so that's doable and you can still be a
dad no but I can't sit there with a
piece of pork if I got to go to a
basketball game or take somebody to a
birthday party yeah that's true you know
I'm saying
you gotta play on these things I mean
those episodes where we would just talk
to two of us and kind of share stories
that talk about our songwriting process
or specific dynamics of our friendship I
think we're
were rays of light of shining away to
wear ear biscuits could ultimately
evolve and we were getting good feedback
on those as well from you guys but I and
and I think that you started to get you
had a mounting frustration with the
interviews more so than me which is
totally fine and I I think it got to a
point where it was like you know I I was
a little later kind of making that
transition but ultimately we both got to
the point where we didn't really have an
appetite for these in-depth interviews I
mean especially when our appetite for
having more conversation started to grow
we can get into that a little bit more
later but I think as far as the the
waning interest in in interviews
whatever was practical you get your
subject to these people guest showing up
having to be booked having to pick
people are they the right kind of
candidate do we want to talk with them
do we have things that say yes it was a
whole thing that was very well and for
me personally I was there were some
guests that I was personally less
motivated to talk to her I was
personally less interested in their
career I mean just being Frank about it
I respected everybody and I learned a
lot I would talk to sometimes have
people and I was like I really don't
know anything about what you do but I'm
gonna take I'm gonna take you know we
would have her like a research period so
we're like we wanted to ask him form
questions and we wanted to know what we
were talking about and so there would be
time that would go into learning about
them watching their videos and then
coming up with some you know semi
intelligent questions and that process
became a little more like homework
to me about a subject that I wasn't
interested in with what you know and I
think that just for me and I think you
couple that with the fact that like I
said we both have a lot to say like we
can we can fill
conversation very very easily both of us
both of us individually have enough
conversation in the tank to talk to one
person the when you all of a sudden you
got the two of us and sometimes there
was there was this like and I think you
had more of a tendency to do this to be
like you had this very specific and we
wouldn't talk about it in a very
specific way that you wanted to conduct
the interview and a specific line of
questioning and so there would be like
maybe a 40-minute period in a podcast
where I would I might just say like yeah
and you know me
that's not my jam and so I that that was
frustrating for me yeah because I was
like yeah yeah let's just talk man we
got plenty to say yeah you know what I
think I'm realizing or at least a
remembering one of the things that
really changed for me in terms of my
appetite for wanting to switch to the
show and make it more about us I had
this mounting guilt maybe guilt a strong
word but I just had a mounting
discomfort over the course of a couple
of years of doing the interviews because
I would make it a practice to push so
hard to get to something juicy to get to
something meaningful and introspective
and new I you know I I took it as a
personal challenge to get past what they
would talk about on other interviews and
really understand not only how they
became successful but what made them
tick if they went through any hardship
it felt important to me to give them an
opportunity to talk about that because I
just felt like that's an important
aspect that that a lot of people didn't
see they see the success they see the
smiles in between you know jump cut
together but they don't see in-between
the jump cuts and you know I really
wanted to
give people an opportunity to to to
analyze that aspect of their their own
selves but I do and I and I did push
kind of hard I asked you know awkward
questions I you know and that's actually
not what bothered me
I think the mounting discomfort was we
were doing we weren't doing that like we
weren't sharing
I think we started talking about it so
like I felt like if if someone would
have done to me what I did to them in
the line of questioning that I presented
I would have been very uncomfortable and
I didn't feel like that was fair I still
don't feel like that was totally fair
and I'm but I'm glad that this venue and
this table has evolved to be a space
where we can process who we are in a way
that I was trying to get other people to
do and I think that that I definitely
recall people commenting about that like
you guys will get so so much personal
stuff from a guest but we don't know a
lot about you personally right oh I play
a clip I didn't mean to cut you off you
can finish your thought that was all I
was gonna say so episode 91 actually we
called it let's get personal released on
April 24th 2017
speaking of Lilly we took her in for
just an annual checkup they had concerns
centered to a specialist and then to
make a very long story short she was
diagnosed with severe scoliosis we get
the x-ray we look at this thing in her
back is like an S when we get in with
the specialist basically the first thing
he told us was these are where her
curves are this is what this means these
are the facts this is what research has
taught us therefore we're recommending
spinal fusion surgery for Lily we left
the doctor's office we went out we got
in the van and it was like three of us
and like we talked about it some more
and we cried you know all three of us
cried of course it was and it is very
scary yeah so
that was I believe before she went in
for surgery and then episode 95 the
world's longest treasure hunt where
Kevin came on and told us about that
totally different format we tried for a
little bit as part of the intro I gave
an update on Lily's recovery we told her
your back straight and she started
crying the surgery went exactly it how
we hoped I mean it went off without a
hitch
it came full circle when we got in the
minivan again leaving the hospital for
the first time and we all looked at each
other and Lily was like we did it now
she's at home recovering she's doing
great but the fact that they went in
there and they put two metal rods that
they custom bent they like they like
smooshed her spine to be back no longer
than s and then they attach those rods
using titanium screws huge screws into
her vertebrae you know how many six
weeks after that she's like fully
recovered here's the thing what a good
insight into let's do somebody do a
somebody do a montage of me trying to
say something to insert something into a
link story Kiki you do that
I thought you talking to Kiko it's like
why'd you call Kiki I understand Kiki
now Kiko Kiki maybe that goes both ways
I don't know that's a good analysis so
wait so that was after we had made the
decision this was well into us making
the decision for the show to just be the
two of us yeah yeah which I don't
remember exactly when that was but yeah
we very well we started saying that the
thing that's gonna drive the majority of
March of 2017 is when we started okay so
this is very close this is very soon
after that because we were like let's
you know more interviews the thing you
know this
stuff that happens to us is going to be
the majority of the fuel for the
conversations that we have right and you
know we've talked about this many people
have made the same observation that some
of the personal stories that used to be
the backbone we're definitely the
backbone of good morning shilling and
the predecessor to GMM and then the
early stages of good mythical morning
very much driven by us having
conversations together
that's where let's talk about that and
moving at the speed of conversation a
lot of that was actually originally GMM
yeah
mode and of course for reasons that most
of you probably understand GMM has
necessarily taken on a different tone
and a different angle and that's why
it's in its 16th it's about to be in its
16th season because we made that change
and then we took the we took that spirit
and we moved it to ear biscuits and I
think that that was even from like a
personal health standpoint was a very
important transition you know because
GMM is like a playground for our
personalities in which we do things that
grown men probably shouldn't do or if
they're gonna do it you might as well
watch them do it and we have fun but
it's not about being personal and it's
any more than just hey this is us
realistically reacting to something in
the moment and kind of having two best
friends having a good time but it's not
two best friends sort of pulling back
the layers of their lives that's not
what GMM is and GM's not ever gonna be
that again but we do have this we have
this place that and gmm wasn't it was
never it was never that it was it it was
never a venue to be as introspective or
everything we did was for the effect of
entertainment like we would tell
personal stories we tell the funny
stories and I don't know how much we we
talked about ear biscuits becoming a
place where
I think the assumption was hey we can
share some funny stories when they
happen at least at the top of an episode
before we get into something topical
which which we still do on many of these
episodes we kind of use that that format
when we're trying to figure out what
we're going to make an episode about but
then we also expanded it to whatever's
going on you know when the thing with
Lily happen that might have been one of
the first things I was like you know
what I think I want to talk about this
and it was at the beginning of that the
first Lily clip it was like speaking of
lily and then I I talked about what was
going on but it wasn't the entire
episode and then for the Kevin thing it
was like hey since I talked about Lily I
want to give you an update you know on
that subsequent clip we played right but
it was it felt good to be able to share
and for us to process as friends
something that was that was such a big
part of my life you know and that's when
I felt like that level of honesty and
introspection was rewarding I think it
just for us to be able to talk about it
even without even knowing how a listener
will respond to it and I maybe that's
part of what you're saying like the more
that we're able to have those type of
conversations it's difficult you know
for us to find the time to have the
conversations that where we're sharing
things about our experience we when this
hits the fan we absolutely talk about
things we don't wait to do that on the
podcast that would be ridiculous
so I'm not saying that it was an
aversion for instance it wasn't like I
didn't know right the update with Lily
but I might not know what you did like
on your vacation that would the funny
story that you're gonna tell about your
RV trying to get out of the driveway
well you're not gonna tell that I'm me
in the same way you don't need to you
can wait that can wait for the pocket
and that's the good good good morning
Chia Lincoln part of it was I'm gonna
tell you this funny story about the RV
we should put that on the internet too
two for one
but then we're both gonna talk about how
what these vacations mean to us as
humans husbands fathers you know pet
owners you know all of those things so
the show started to well it evolved but
it started to morph a little bit and I I
should just give a quick update on Lily
since we've talked about her you know
it's been over two years we celebrated a
two-year anniversary of her surgery and
she had been rollerskating recently and
somebody came up and clipped her from
behind and knocked her on her butt and
then she like fell on her back and like
it was the first time that we were
actually scared and everything just
popped out yeah
her whole spine he's just kind of like
Mortal Kombat ya know she she had some
bruised ribs but nothing it just so
happened that her annual checkup for
with the spine doctor was within the
week so that put our minds at rest when
they did the x-ray and said you know
what everything is totally fine it's all
metal infused it's after 2 years
stronger than a normal spine well the
screws that they used to put the rods in
by this point in time it's like he's
totally become one right it's all grown
together so actually in the first year
so there is a chance of MORTAL KOMBAT of
know of the screws getting loose right
and then having to do something so we've
passed that milestone her number of
checkups are going down to where they
don't have to be every year anymore so
it was a miraculous surgery and we're
grateful for it she's doing fabulous and
she has no physical restrictions and she
she has this scar that still she wears
as a badge of honor and you know it's
like when she has one of the shorter
shirts that these girls are wearing now
it's like you can see the belt I
wouldn't call it a midriff but if you
bend over you can see a little bit of
the scar and it's like I'm proud every
time I see it and I'm proud that she's
fine like with her bit with a bathing
suit on hanging out with her
friends it's like it's not anything
she's embarrassed about and she's had
many conversations over the past two
years with other people who are faced
with the same surgery or a similar
condition and she's able to see how she
can her experience can enrich the lives
of other people and give them support so
it's it's it's it was scary it was it
was life-changing for all of us and it
continues to be and yeah I think I have
a like I have a personal I'm annoyed by
like sentimentality porn okay I'll use
that for lack of a better word meaning
I'm going to say something sentimental
or I'm gonna do something I'm gonna
share something sentimental because I
know that it will affect the audience
and us in a certain way in its
manipulation
you know that's it's a it's a
manipulation thing and so I think that
there are there are definitely like when
you talk about like vlogging like
personal vlogs where people are like
I've made a decision that I'm gonna
share my life with you I think you get
into a place where you start hoping that
you're going to experience things that
then we'll make like deep moving
material that just grows your audience
right and I just want to be clear that
that's not what we that's not what we do
on your biscuits I think that's probably
clear but that's one of the reasons that
we don't only format the show to be
about personal things because if if we
said it's always personal every single
time it's gonna be about what's going on
in our lives
then you begin to script your life for
the sake of the content that you're
creating yeah I think that's one of the
reasons that I've and I don't have
anything against people who have daily
vlogs or family vlogs but I would be
lying to you if I didn't say that almost
all of them without exception annoy me
and in sort of I think one of the things
that annoy
me about it is this just like your
family has become a show and at that
point you begin to make decisions where
the content is driving the way you live
your life as opposed to the way you live
your life just being the content listen
I understand the guy I can only imagine
what it would feel like to be in that
kind of cycle and I'm glad that I'm not
in that cycle but with with your
biscuits it's like if something happens
you know and and I think that you know
just statistically or circumstantially
whatever you know you've kind of had you
know you I haven't had this situation
happened with I had that happen with my
kid I haven't had a medical situation
with my kid
I haven't had a close relative died like
your grandfather died I haven't had my
mom's husband who incidentally is my dad
you know hasn't been through a difficult
time in the hospital so Lincoln shared a
lot of those things and some about
saying that link is doing sentimentality
porn I'm just saying that as things
happen if we feel that they're
appropriate we're going to talk about
them and we're gonna process them
together because we're purposely
choosing to format the episodes in a way
that gives us the ability to share
personal things but doesn't make the
point on obnoxious to be sharing
personal things at which point I feel
like we would be hoping that things
would happen or sensationalizing things
that are happening to us for urine or to
entertainment in in in again this is
this is a business we we do this in part
so that we can get money from sponsors
that we can grow our business and
mythical entertainment I mean that we
would be dishonest if we did if we
weren't transparent about that but I
think more than that it has become a
place for us to process the things that
we are experiencing and also you know
just be like hey we're going to be open
about our lives we're going to be open
about what it's like to be to run a
business to be a best friend to be a
husband to be a father as these things
happen to us we're going to try to
accurately portray them and just share
our
experience and I've really tried to
understand what my personal boundaries
are for sharing and what the objective
of that is and I will say I will also
acknowledge that yes that you haven't
had things happen in your life since
we've been sharing this type of stuff on
your biscuits that have had this like
headline material sensational type thing
like the stuff that you listed that I've
shared about but that's not to say I
mean I couldn't have predicted I
would've been sharing those things if
you would have told me all I said I can
believe you but I don't know how we'll
get there
I don't know that you would have
predicted that you would be sharing
openly about therapy and the things that
you're learning but I think that it's
you know to your credit I think it's you
are you're also doing that I mean we're
honestly processing our lives and that's
what this show has become it's
processing our lives and our
perspectives and but I 107 agree that
it's not not with an obligation to
overshare especially to the point of
sensationalizing things or hoping that
something sensational happens right but
in terms of my boundary I just and even
though we've done episodes where they
were advice themed I never want to turn
my personal experience at back at the
audience as advice you know I just want
to honestly process and then you know if
if I'm honest then you as a listener can
take whatever is valuable to you that's
up to you but it's I'm I try to be
disciplined to not turn my experience
into advice for somebody else even
though I do like giving advice and I
like feeling like I'm right about stuff
but I I'm very grateful with the way
that your business has expanded I think
that
again this is not the primary venue for
us to have the deepest converse the
deepest deepest conversations that we
have but is that that middle ground of
conversation you know being able to tell
this story for comedic effect and us to
experience that together is really fun
that's really great for our relationship
and also when we get into the
introspective aspects of I told you the
RV story yeah that was funny but then
we're going to talk about our vacations
and I think we do get it things that
it's that middle ground a conversation
that's kind of like you find yourself
being introspective at a point where we
probably would have just moved on to
working otherwise right so I do think
that I'm very happy with her with where
biscuits is for that reason and then
I'll say secondarily I've been very
encouraged pleasantly surprised that the
more that we have been honest about our
perspectives and our experiences that
listeners have related to it and that
they've that it's helped them in some
way you know and yeah it's it's been one
of them the most encouraging things from
people that we meet on tour yeah and you
know of course there's lots people who
are like the bright spot the GMM
represents in my day has been
transformative for me emotionally and
again we'd never intended that but the
fact that that's a reality is just
something that blows us away but I think
that when somebody says ear biscuits has
I just you know this particular thing
that you talked about change the way
that I approach this thing or thought
about this thing in my life again not
from hey we're giving you advice
usually the advice that we give is for
some stupid situation and for the sake
of entertainment but just you know when
you hear somebody talk about something
that there's a
there's a touch point in your life and
you're seeing how they're navigating it
it's just that's just how humans relate
to each other you know it's not like hey
look at me and do what we did but it's
just like hey I'm just gonna share
honestly about this I mean any
relationship and I do think that it's
not just the relationship that we have
with each other it's the relationship
that we have with you listening anytime
that you're just open about something
that's going on that enhances yeah
there's the opportunity for that to
enhance your life and that's something
it's a responsibility I think that we
didn't design the show to ever have but
I think it does now and so when we think
about that you know when we're sharing
something that we're going through and
they were very very much aware that
there are individuals out there who are
going through something very similar
potentially or will go through something
similar and if that can you know improve
their experience then that that alone
makes this whole thing worth it and from
a Content standpoint just to get a
little more practical I'm very
encouraged when I see when my heart
sinks a little bit when I look at the
the if I see the good mythical morning
or the rhett and Link reddit thread and
like the a new entry will pop up where
somebody says I miss the old good
mythical morning or this is what I don't
like about good mythical morning or I
miss good morning Chia Lincoln and then
inevitably the conversation very quickly
turns to it sounds like ear biscuits is
perfect for you you know so I'm it's
funny that I I don't know how much we
talked about it and I don't know how
intentional it was but as good mythical
morning has evolved then ear biscuits
also evolved to fill a desire for
something that no longer is the chief
dynamic of that show which is just
unstructured conversation that gets to
personal stories that are that are funny
and as we've got
it goes a lot further than that so I'm
I'm just I'm glad to be 200 episodes
into something that we didn't get
complacent and that we did but we we
continued to want to express ourselves
creatively and to and to find a way to
be engaged because I think that anything
then this is what happened you
anticipate going for an extended period
of time you know as a performer if
you're creating a product that does
require you to perform on some level
this is this I mean we're believe it or
not we are performing and what in one
sense because we're not just talking to
each other we're having a conversation
and in this context where you're
listening anytime you can transform that
into something that does not feel like a
burden I think you're in a good place
and not only does this not feel like a
burden but this feels like an outlet for
us yeah you know we're and I gotta be
honest with the interviews they began to
feel like a burden yeah when I went when
I looked at my schedule back in the day
and it was like all you got to do in
your biscuit and you're not prepared for
that person it felt like you got a test
but when I see you've got a near biscuit
today on the schedule and even if I
haven't prepared for it I'm like oh
that's one of the that's something I
look forward to some it's a creative
outlet and it is a mental outlet it's an
emotionalless
it's a lot of things for us and so yeah
I'm I'm grateful for what it is for us
and I'm grateful for what it is for you
listening and I just want to thank you
for for listening at what point you
started listening that's fine
maybe you don't want to go back and
listen to all of them that's also fine
I'm it what's most important is that
you're here and that you enjoy hanging
out with us putting us in your ears
thank you for sharing your biscuits with
other people yeah
anybody that you you know that what this
show has become if you think that they
would connect with it don't be afraid to
tell them about it
so what will the next 200 episodes hold
we don't have time to get into that now
maybe we will at another point unless
you want to make a quick Troye Sivan
prediction episode 400 what what will
let me get your palm oh you sure you
want to know I thought if that means you
really have to come up with something
that's gonna be underwhelming if you got
something good yes if you don't let's
just keep it a mystery okay let's keep
it up okay but I do have a quick reckon
effect I'm gonna leave you with this is
one that link has a little insight into
because I shared this wreck with him
yesterday and I shared this wreck not so
much as a pure recommendation that
you're that I'm going all in on this
because I have questions about this
wreck that I want you to explore with me
okay now you may know we've talked about
this before primitive technology one of
our favorite YouTube channels this guy
somewhere in Australia who does all this
stuff with Stone Age tools never talks
there's no music he never looks at the
camera and you just build stuff and it's
amazing well as you might expect he
essentially created a genre of YouTube
videos and now there are other people
following suit and doing the same thing
there is a guy I'm gonna say this wrong
but his channel is mr. young update and
I believe it's mr. got a you and Gia no
H II ang there's no you how long I think
but there's no space after the period
and Mister either at least on the
YouTube channel mr. young update and
he's got a bunch of videos there's two
from the past a couple months that he
built this under grant well this is the
confusing thing linking out watch both
videos
using a stick he dug into a huge pit and
it's like this incredible dwelling he
made a submerged dwelling that has a
pool in it in the bottom of it there is
a pool and he did one video like a 15
minute long video where he does this and
it's awesome and then he did a second
video which included the footage from
the same exact video was released around
the same time but then he put a roof on
it yeah and made it where you couldn't
see it at all it was like it wasn't even
there it's at regardless of the nature
of how this all happens it is amazing
and you should watch that but the
assignment and the question is what the
assignment is between those two videos
like what will I don't understand why
you decided to do one with a roof and
one without a roof release him around
the same time and include footage of
both things but also if you go and look
at other things
I feel like with primitive technology
every single thing that he does is
documented and you know that he didn't
get any help my question about mr. hyung
is is he really doing all this himself
I want to believe I want to believe he's
doing it all himself but I have my
suspicions because first of all we know
he has a camera man because the camera
moves when he's in the don't give him
the answers let him look into it
primitive technology doesn't seem to
have a camera man but there's also many
steps and mr. hyung's process that you
don't see that's the wreck in effect I
also highly recommend it and thank you
for celebrating 200 episodes y'all hmm
hashtag ear biscuits let us know what
you think of the evolution of your
biscuits we'll talk at you next week to
watch more ear biscuits click on the
playlist on the right to watch the
previous episode of your biscuits click
on the playlist to the left and don't
forget to click on the circular icon to
subscribe if you prefer to listen to
this podcast it's available on all your
favorite podcast platforms thanks for
being your mythical best
[Music]